- One music video.
- For the next year.
- For the next year?
- 365--
- Six months.
- No. The next year--
- I'm trying to--
- I'm gonna have a baby,
things are gonna happen.
- That's what I'm saying too
I'm freaking the fuck out.
- Yeah. Had a fucking baby.
What the fuck? It's crazy.
(group laughter)
I know how you do it.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
- [Gary] Or their subjective
call on creative instead of
creating the process that allows
more creative to see the day of
light and be able to see the
quant and qual feedback from it.
So, it's the human beings in the
way of letting more creative see
the world and they're reacting
to the creative instead of
having the ego that
we're the individuals
that pick the creative.
("Flying" by Caesar)
Good, how are you?
Good to see you.
I can't be your mentor, Phil.
- You already are.
- [Gary] I know, it's so weird.
It's so binary,
if I'm on your team,
I'm all the way there.
I just stop, like the faucet
of awesomeness and love and
opportunity just turns off.
That you've seen a lot.
- Murdering!
- [Gary] It's the tortoise
and the hare. Right.
- Don't even. Don't even,
don't deflect that.
You're killing it.
You entertain me three
or four times a fucking day.
Excuse my language.
(Gary blows raspberry)
Did I say excuse my language?
(group laughter)
For God's sake,
but you told me that.
You sat me down in a room, when
I first met you and I'd known
you for about five
minutes and you said,
"You're gonna have a million
followers this time next year"
and I laughed.
- I remember.
- And you said,
"No, you're going to."
You were like, "What the
fuck doesn't this kid get?"
You're like,
"Everybody's going to."
I know youd didn't
quite mean that but--
- What do you mean,
I didn't mean it?
- Are you getting
what I'm saying?
- We were in 315, and I was
just building out that office.
I knew exactly--
- Yeah.
- I told all of you fuckers
what you were going to be.
So, to me, let's
take a step back.
- Sure.
- Instead of what
you're doing right now,
one man's point of view.
In trying to win in a way that
I think you have less control.
- [Nicholas] Sure.
- And the majority of people are
trying to go through that path.
- [Nicholas] Sure.
- My question is do you believe
that you can
replicate your social reach...
("Flying" by Caesar)
If you decided to
create for Musical.ly,
decided to create for Instagram,
create for the platform, not
create the romantic thing you've
decided that you are you can
replicate it if you choose
that's the right move.
Only thing I'm doing for you
'cause I love you is giving you
the permission to
understand that truth.
- I get it. What's plan B?
- Plan B is to be like everybody
else in this town and fucking be
at the mercy of organizations
that don't give
a fuck about you.
- Okay.
- That's plan B, mother fucker.
- That's great.
What a horrifying reality
that you've painted for me.
- That's plan B!
- I got to tell you something.
- Yes, sir.
- My dad's first
generation Greek.
- Uh-huh.
- And I think that's why I
love you because this is like my
father talking to me.
Except you're way
younger than my dad.
But I'm telling you--
- Dude, I was
hoping I was older.
("Flying" by Caesar)
- [Nicholas] So
you're saying everyday
I'm doing one music video,--
- For the next year.
- For the next year?
- 365--
- Six months.
- No. The next year--
- I'm trying to--
- I'm gonna have a baby,
things are gonna happen.
- That's what I'm saying too
I'm freaking the fuck out.
- Yeah. Had a fucking baby.
What the fuck? It's crazy.
(group laughter)
I know how you do it.
You're really, you
know what's interesting?
You know what's
interesting about that?
You know what, do you want to
know what's most interesting
about that moment?
- What?
- You're so good at what
you did and what you do,--
- You were able to--
- I was able to
give it that style,
that's, that was
actually incredible moment.
I consume no content.
- I know. I know.
- That's it.
The fact that you have something
like that I'm not gonna
let you fucking waste it.
- Plug it on this.
- What the fuck do you think
this whole episode's
gonna be about?
- So for the next 365 days--
- This man, right
here, is going to?
- be making a song
a day on Instagram.
- Who's freaking the fuck out?
I can't curse on this channel?
- You can curse. Fuck yeah.
Cool.
(Gary and DRock laugh)
That's it. Love you, man.
Wow.
- [Gary] I'm pumped up, man.
Dude, I swear to God on
my life, I'm telling you,
I'm gonna say something weird.
- What?
- This is where it gets weird.
- It's pretty weird already.
- I will never talk to you again
if there's not a video tomorrow.
- You will never
talk to me ever again?
- I swear on my children.
- Wow.
Can you say
that on my Instagram?
- Nope.
- Can you say
that on my Instagram?
- Nope.
(Phil laughs)
- Say it!
- No.
This is for you and me.
- That's gonna go on that.
- Listen.
Listen, listen, listen.
- What's up?
- I love you.
Sit down for one more second.
I really need this.
- Go ahead.
- This is very serious.
- I'm sweating.
("Flying" by Caesar)
That's the reason I'm here, man.
I believe in you and
I know you believe in me.
- [Gary] I do, brother.
Love you very much.
- Incredible success.
- Thank you.
I'll talk to you soon.
- Nobody deserves
it like you, man.
- I'll talk to you tomorrow.
- Peace! Peace out!
Peace, (mumbles).
Alright. Alright, guys.
- [Gary] Guys,
I'm fucking fired up.
You wanna watch, you're
excited about the content.
You're excited about
bananas fit in circles.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Which is
gonna be a huge hit.
But don't mentors have more
experience and connections?
Yes, but if you do work.
And what people don't understand
that really pisses me off is
they're not
creating any leverage.
Everything is
about fucking leverage.
Look at you two
fucking jerkoffs.
You guys had leverage 'cause you
came and worked for free that
was your leverage that
created your opportunity.
People fucking
hitting up people on DM like,
"Hey Mark Cuban, I want
you to be my mentor."
With what fucking
leverage, asshole?
So either you go and do it from
scratch and build something that
gives you leverage like if
fucking young Mark Zuckerberg or
young Evan Spiegel wants
to hit me up and says hey,
I'm like yeah, hey.
You build something,
you've got something.
Or you fucking do something that
brings disproportionate value
to the other person which is
the only thing is free work
of a skill that people need.
But then
everybody cries and goes,
"I don't do spec work.
That's the value of me."
Everybody, you know?
Ridiculous argument because the
value of you is your whole life
not fucking six weeks,
six months or a year.
Nobody understands,
this is all leverage.
It's all leverage.
People don't want to work, man.
People don't want to work.
I know you agree, you did it.
Phil, how'd you get
into Forbes 30 under 30 or
whatever fucking
list you're on? You know?
There's no fucking way you
were gonna do it other
than did something smart.
You did something
smart and rogue.
even more interesting.
Not only did you,
you did two things right.
You asked, most people
don't even fucking ask,
and you ate crow.
You asked twice.
- [DRock] I asked a
lot more than twice.
- You asked more than twice?
- [DRock] Yes.
- You need to
dig up those emails.
That's a real fucking blog post.
- [DRock] Emails and tweets.
- You need to find
every one of them, DRock.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- You have enormous
amounts of down time,
go figure it out.
(group laughter)
("Free Animal"' by Foreign Air)
I wish you well, brother.
Good to see you.
- Good luck.
- [Gary] Good luck to
you on everything, alright?
Hey guys. Hey.
I want to do a 24 hour
Q&amp;A live globally. Right?
Like, think about that.
Yeah, it's different thing,
you know?
You okay?
What is this thing?
(man laughs)
I'm just kidding.
- Can I get one?
- [Gary] Yeah, let's do it.
22.
- That's right.
One of the biggest things,--
- Sell your truth, baby.
Sell your truth.
- That's right.
- Awesome. You too,
man, I'm proud of you.
Keep hustlin'.
- You don't understand.
I read your book "Jab, Jab,
Right Hook" I was from Watts.
- [Gary] Yes.
- No one makes it out of there.
- [Gary] I understand
what Watts is.
- Read that book, ate shit for
three years building this up.
Did Good Morning America was
able to scale it from that,
now we're launching in Target.
So I wanted to tell you...
("Free Animal"' by Foreign Air)
- You did it. You did it,
I just gave you that match.
Love it, love it.
- I loved everything that he
said tonight but one thing that
really resonated with me
was how you talked about
we can control our hustle.
I get so many people asking
how do you accomplish this?
How do I do that?
And how do I do that?
- You work.
- Yeah. Work your ass off.
- Work.
- Anything else you want
to say to my channel, Gary?
- Yep, work.
- (laughs) Thank you.
- Awesome.
Did it. We did it.
It was a lot of fun.
Big ups L.A.
There's a bus?
- [DRock] (laughs) I don't know.
- [Gary] Look.
Hope you guys enjoyed it.
Yeah, of course. See ya.
See you guys, take care.
A good day.
No, I'm not tired.
- Hoping outside right now.
- Not gonna catch me
sleeping ever again.
- [DRock] Oh, I will. I will.
- [Tyler] Fantastic.
I'll see you in one second.